You are you, there's no one else like you...
and you're not like anyone else, you're a true original.
What we have in common is that we're all unique.
Balance believes that how you meditate should reflect who you are...
...which is why this approach is different.
Balance adapts to you for whatever reason you're on this journey,...
...however long you've been here and no matter where you're headed.
You're asked questions every step of the way...
...like which techniques you enjoy, how fast you're learning...
...and what you want out of your experience...
...and each guided meditation adjusts to meet your needs.
With thousands of paths diverging from your responses...
...meaning you build core meditation skills at your own pace.
And the route you take is as unique as you.
We know that meditation isn't one-size-fits-all.
Balance brings you a truly personalized approach because you're you.